اكثر من 125 ساعه تمكنوا الان من توسيع
فوهه الثغره نايف السفليه
ويحاولون ازاله الانقاض ويقومون بازالتها
ازاله هذه الانقاض هكذا هكذا هو المشهد
نايف في جميع المناطق المنكوبه الكل يسابق
الزمن والكل كتفا بكتف لازاله حجر وركام
وحديد الكل يعمل بكل ما هو متاح لازاله
هذه الانقاض والوصول الى العالقين الناجين
تحت الانقاض
ويعني الامل يحدوهم بان يتمكنوا من انقاذ
المزيد من العالقين لكن يبقى نعود مجددا
الى النقطه الرئيسيه وهي عامل الوقت يبقى
عامل الوقت هو العامل الاكثر اهميه ونحن
بعد سته ايام بعد اكثر من 125 ساعه
تقل وتتضاءل فرص النجانيف لكن ما زال هناك
عمر جديد مكتوب لهؤلاء وما زالت الاعمال
متواصله يعني اخواتها تحت الانقاذ التي
اخرجنا طبعا من نفس المبنى ومن تحت ومن
ذات الكومه كومه
كومه الانقاض في هذا المبنى اذا الجهود لا
تزال مستمره كما ذكرت هنا استخدام يعني
ادوات الحفر التقليديه ربما في هذه الصوره
يبدو انه وصلوا الى الى الى مراحل يعني
حددوا فيها بدقه مكان وجود الفتاه عائشه
قبل قليل يعني شاهدنا ابعاد واستخراج يعني
احد
احد الاجسام الثقيله الموجوده الاجسام
الاسمنتيه الموجوده طبعا في هذا المبنى
الان عمليه الحفر تقليديه يدويه يعني مع
كل فرق الانقاذ والتي يبدو انها اصبحت
يعني تزيد هذه
الاعداد اعداد فرق الانقاذ والطوارئ في
هذا في هذا المكان بشكل يعني ملحوظ بشكل
متابع وربما لان كذلك هناك صعوبه في يعني
استخراج وانتشال يعني ناجين من تحت انقاذ
هذا المبنى ربما طبعا لاسباب يعني
لاسباب تتعلق طبعا بالحديد الاسمنت ايضا
المسلح ذو الوزن الثقيل والعالي جدا في
هذه
المنطقه في هذا المبنى ايضا تحديد العرض
اي خطا اي خطا ممكن ان يكون كارثه في هذه
الحاله اي خطا ممكن ان يكون كارثه انت
تشاهد الطبقات كيف متراكمه وكيف متراصه
وفوق بعضها وبالتالي اي شيء ممكن ان يسحب
بشكل خاطئ او يزال بشكل خاطئ ممكن ان يزيد
من تعقيد العمليه
ويحدث انهيارًا جديدا وبالتالي تتم بشكل
يعني المتاني ودقيق هم يعملون بسرعه في
هذه النقطه لانهم يدركون جيدا بان الطبقه
العليا ثابته لا يمكن ان تتحرك وبالتالي
لديهم مساحه من الحركه والسرعه في هذه
النقطه السفليه اما بالنقطه العلويه ما
زالوا ايضا كما نشاهد يواصلون رفع الانقاذ
من تلك الحفره وايضا يقومون بقطع الحديد
نايف تتسارع هذه الوتيره نايف منذ دقائق
تحديدا بعدما استخدموا كاميرا حراريه
ويبدو انهم حددوا الموقع بالضبط ويواصلون
هذه العمليه وهناك مؤشر جيد نايف
مؤشر بان الفتاه ما زالت على قيد الحياه
صمت
اذا لحظه من الصمت يعيشها
المنقذون المسعفون الفرق الموجوده ايضا
كذلك وحتى لحظه صمت بين الصحفيين
الموجودين طبعا في هذه المنطقه محاوله
لسماع صوت هذه
الطفله التي لا يزال البحث عنها جاري حتى
هذه اللحظه كما ذكرنا بعد ان تم
استخراج
شقيقاتها من تحت الانقاض ويبدو انهم
يحاولون الان فرق الانقاذ ان يستخرجوها من
تحت الانقاض وبعد طبعا ان تم اخراج
شقيقتين
كنت اقول قبل قليل نايف ان كنت تسمعني
كنت اقول قبل قليل ان يعني هذا التسارع في
وتيره العمل هو مؤشر جيد على ما يبدو لانه
لو كانت لا سمح الله قد فارقت الحياه لما
كانوا يعني بهذا النشاط وبهذه السرعه في
الاداء والعمل لكنهم يبدو ان
اقتربوا كثيرا ووضع الفتاه يعني قريب من
الخروج فبالتالي يسارعون في وتيره العمل
وهذا شيء مطمئن وجيد وكما تشاهد يعني كيف
السرعه في عمليه الاخراج كيف السرعه في
خمس اخراج نعم نعم نعم سريعه جدا ان شاء
الله تخرج عائشه هذه اللحظه المنتظره
واللحظه الحاسمه والفارقه طبعا في عمليه
انقاذ هذه الطفله الطفله عائشه الجهود
ايضا كبيره نتابعها الان ويبدو بان يعني
حتاذه هذه الجهود وسرعتها ايضا تدل بان
العمليه اصبحت قاب قوسين او ادنى من ان
تتم ان شاء الله بشكل امن وسليم بان يتم
اخراج
ايضا من تحت الانقاض كنا قد تابعنا قبل
قليل يعني مع ادوات مختلفه في الحفر
مختلفه احد احد المنقذين نايف احد فقط
طلبوا منا ان نصمت مره مره اخرى
الان الان الفرق نايف لحظه نايف الان فرق
الانقاذ تطلب من خال طفلا النزول طبعا احد
عناصر الانقاذ ابلغني قبل قليل يعني
بالاشاره لا ادري ان كنت فهمت عليه جيدا
انه يعني ربما خلال عشر دقائق ممكن يعني
نتمكن من اخراجها يطلبون الصمت مجددا
وربما دعوه الخال لاستخراجها وانقاذها
يعني هذا ما نتمناه بصراحه غسان بعد هذا
الوقت
الطويل ايضا والانتظار المضني ايضا
نتابع
فقط
طلبوا ان نصمت لكن اود ان اعطيك هذه
المعلومه يعني احد عناصر الانقاذ حسب احد
الاشخاص الذي ترجم لي الان قال انه يعني
ممكن بعد عسكر
انتشال الفتاه نعم
والان عناصر الانقاذ طلبت من خال الطفله
ان يقترب من الثغره حتى على ما اعتقد يعني
يستقبلها او يحملها
فهي بوادر بوادر جيده وبوادر مفرحه يعني
حتى هذه اللحظه لكنها عشر دقائق نايف
بالنسبه يعني للكل للجميع هي عشر ساعات
صراحه
ربما من المكان على ما يبدو هذا احد
الاشخاص
خلق عائشه ايوه نعم نعم الان يقول بانه
نايف ممكن
[موسيقى]
لو سمحت تتكلم عربي اتكلم عربي خلينا بس
لو سمحت
اخواتي من تحت الانقاذ من تحت هذه
يعني
سنحاول فقط ان نسال الشخص الذي هل وزن
الثقيل جدا وسوابق المختلفه
اخذ مقابله مع خال الطفله الذي كان في
الحفره هي بعيده في مسافه بعيده بالحفره
الصوت مبين انه قريب الصوت البنت الصغيره
بس صوتها تعبانه جوه مشان هيك ما بتحسن
تعلي صوتك بس المكان لازم قريب ما هو بعيد
قريب يعني انت كم المسافه اللي دخلتها
تقريبا دخلت بحدود للمترونات تقريبا مثل
جون سمعتها شو حكت لك بالضبط سالتها انت
وين عطي صوتك قالت لي انا هون فقط بس
الحمد لله يعني نايف كما استمعت لخال
الطفل الذي كانت داخل الثغرات تحدث وتواصل
مع ابنه شقيقته وتاكد بانها على قيد
الحياه
سالها اين انت قلت له انا هنا في
واكد بان الصوت كان قريب هو تحدث عن مسافه
متر ونصف تقريبا من فوهه الثغره وبالتالي
يعني ان شاء الله تكون يعني المسافه قريبه
جدا ويتمكنوا من اخراجها لكن المهم حتى
هذه اللحظه نايف ان الطفله على قيد الحياه
وتتجاوب وليست في حاله غيبوبه وهذا اهم
شيء بالنسبه للطفله صحيا
يعني نتوقع خلال دقائق ربما ان تخرج
الطفله عائشه من الحفره عمليات صعبه جدا
نايف صعبه جدا يعني ساعات ودقائق
وعمليه معقده وصعبه ومهلكه جس ونفسيا
للجميع سواء كانت من فرق الانقاذ او من
الاهالي الذين يتابعون هذه العمليات
يعني حتى حتى يعني الذين يتابعون هذه
اللحظات يعني الصعبه الكل يشعر بان يعني
عائشه اخته او ابنته او او ايضا قريبته
ايضا كذلك في هذه الصور لانها ربما صور
انسانيه اكثر وتعبر عن كما ذكرت بانها
حاله ربما قد تكون حاله عامه هذه الحاله
التي نشاهد محاوله انقاذ الاطفال النساء
ايضا الرجال ايضا حتى من تحت الابنيه التي
انهارت ودمرت بشكل كامل بعد الزلزال الذي
ضرب هذه المناطق ربما ان نشاهد هنا يعني
قطع كبيره
نعم قطاع تدفئه هذه كبيره هذه يعني اكيد
كانت تشكل عائق على
مرتضين في تحركهم جدا وهذا يؤشر على يعني
مدى اتساع الثغره من الداخل وبالتالي مدى
تقدم فرق الانقاذ في الوصول الى الفتاه
وبحسب يعني احد عناصر فرق الانقاذ قبل
قليل ابلغنا بانه يعني ربما خلال عشر
دقائق او بعد عشر دقائق ربع ساعه من الان
ممكن ان يتمكنوا من الوصول اليها لحظه صمت
جديده نايف اذا لحظه صمت مره اخرى نتابعها
معكم مشاهدينا الكرام في تغطتنا الحيه
والمباشره والمستمر في عمليه انقاذ الطفله
عائشه ذات السبعه اعوام وهي التي يعني لا
زالت فرق الانقاذ تبحث عنها تحاول ان تحدد
مكانها بدقه بعد ان تم تحديد
مكان اخواتها ايضا وتم اخراجهن من تحت
الانقاذ قبل ساعتين واكثر من الان
قليل شاهدنا صور
لنزول خال هذه الطفله الى داخل الحفره
ومحاوله مناداتها ايضا اجابته بانها لا
تزال عائشه وبانها موجوده بالقرب من دخل
طبعا تقريبا قرابه متر ونصف متر كما ذكر
اكد خالد طفله بانها لا زالت على قيد
الحياه وبانها الطفله مره اخرى معه مره
اخرى الان ربما صحيح يستدعون خالها مره
ثانيه سنشاهد فرق الانقاذ الشرطه ايضا
كذلك ربما موجوده امامنا الان
وكذلك المسعفين وايضا فرق للانقاذ والحفر
امامنا الان نشاهد هذا هو حال الطفل وربما
نحن في لحظه الصمت كما ذكرت
لمحاوله البحث بشكل دقيق بشكل امن بشكل لا
يؤثر على سلامه الطفله عائشه ذات السبعه
اعوام الموجوده خال لا زال ايضا يراقب
يحاول ايضا
يعني انقاذ الطفله عائشه ان طلب منه ذلك
لا تزال ادوات الحفر وادوات ايضا كذلك
تقطيع الحديد والقضبان الموجوده ازاله
ربما الحواجز الاسمنتيه الخرسانيه المسلحه
ايضا ذات الوزن الثقيل من المكان وهي
تحتاج الى ادوات ما بين متوسطه الى خفيفه
شاهدنا استخدام الكاميرات الحراريه ايضا
كذلك لمحاوله تحديد ما كانت الفتاه قد
توفيت ام هي على قيد الحياه ولا تزال ولله
الحمد على قيد الحياه حتى الان يعني هذا
بعد تاكيد خالها طبعا الكلاب ايضا المدربه
التي شاهدناها ربما في بدايه هذا البث
المباشر وهي طبعا كلاب مدربه
يعني
تحاول طبعا التاكد ان كانت
يعني الطفله لا تزال عائشه بالداخل املاك
كذلك ايضا استخدام الكاميرات الحراريه
وايضا تكسير الانقاض ذكرنا بان هذا المبنى
نعلم بانه قد يعني انهار بشكل كامل منذ
125 ساعه وتزيد عن ذلك منذ سته ايام من
الان لا تزال فرق الانقاذ تحاول اخراج
الطفله عائشه ونحن نشاهد واياكم حتى فرق
الانقاذ قبل قليل كان يتحدث بان امامهم
تقريبا عشر دقائق للوصول الى طفلان قضى
منها حتى هذه اللحظه اكثر من نصف الوقت
ونحن بالانتظار نتمنى يعني ان يكون الوقت
اقل من ذلك لمحاوله انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
خالد طفله قبل قليل يؤكد بان الطفل لا
تستطيع ان تتحدث بصوت عالي وربما ذلك يعني
مؤكد ومعلوم
بسبب وجودها في هذا المكان منذ سته ايام
حتى الان بلا ما بلا تدفئه بلا اكل او
يعني مياه وفي ظل ظروف جويه قاسيه درجات
حراره ايضا تصل الى الصفر وما دون الصفر
[موسيقى]
والان نتابع ربما لحظه صمت اخرى بين
المنقذين وافراد الشرطه ايضا وخال الطفل
الموجود امامنا في الصوره محاوله لسماع
وتحديد موقع الطفله
عائشه ذات سبعه اعوام بشكل دقيق الزميل
غسان ابو اللوز كان يتابع ولا زال يتابع
معي حتى هذه اللحظه عمليات الانقاذ لكنه
ايضا جزء من الموجودين في هذا المكان وحول
الطفله عائشه وربما الصمت
يسود في المكان نحاول ان نستمع الى الصوت
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
صحيح الان نتحدث عن الاعلى قطع كبيره قطع
كبيره
هذا شيء جيد نايف ومؤشر جيد عندما
يستخرجون هذه القطعه الكبيره من هذه
الثغره وهذا يعني يسهل عليهم عمليه الحركه
وعمليه الدخول واستخراج الطفله عائشه من
الداخل تتسارع وتيره العمل يقومون
باستخدام الادوات اليدويه
لتحطيم الركام في الداخل واخراجه نعم
يقومون باخراجه بشكل سريع جدا
وان شاء الله كما قالوا لنا يعني دقائق
وتخرج عائشه يطلبون الصمت نحن امام لحظه
صمت جديده اخرى في موقع
الحدث
المبنى المنهار طبعا على الطفل عائشه وعلى
عائلتها بقيت وحيده تحت الانقاض الان في
هذه اللحظات
الزميل غسان يتابع ايضا معنا
لحظه بلحظه دق التفاصيل حول هذه العمليه
وكما ذكرنا بانه في عرف يعني محاولات
دائما الانقاذ
واستخراج طبعا او انتشال
ناجين من داخل كومه الانقاض فهناك لحظات
صمت احيانا
يطلبها المسعفون والمنقذون لتحديد دقه
ومحاوله الحصول اليها يعملون بشكل سريع
صحيح السرعه يعني وبخطاء ثابته وسريعه
نلاحظ انهم يعني طلبوا فتره صمت يعني في
في وقت في اوقات قياسيه يعني خلال تقريب
الربع ساعه طلبوا مرتين او ثلاث مرات
النصمت وهم بالتالي يعني هذا مؤشر جيد
يبدو انهم يقتربون يريدون تحديدا بالضبط
اين هي ثم يعودون الى الحفر سريعا وهذا
ايضا مؤشر جيد ومؤشر مطمئن حتى هذه اللحظه
نايف وما زالوا يواصلون العمل من الاعلى
ايضا يقومون بتحطيم الركام من الاعلى ومن
الاسفل لكن ما نشاهده هنا من الاسفل يتم
اخراج كميات كبيره من الركام وقطع كبيره
وهذه اكيد بالتاكيد كانت تشكل عائق امام
المنقذين خلال عمليه الانقاذ وخلال عمليه
الحفر يبدو انها العمليه بدات تتسهل شيئا
فشيئا
ويقتربون اكثر فاكثر الى الطفله عائشه
يعني كما اشرت لك نايف الكل يترقب هذه
اللحظات الكل يترقب خروج عائشه الكل يترقب
ان تتنفس عائشه الهواء الطلق مجددا
هذا المشهد ينطبق على جميع الاماكن
والمناطق التي تعاني من الحطام
الرجال الامن هنا يطلبون من المواطنين
الابتعاد عن الموقع لانهم علموا بان هناك
شخص ما على قيد الحياه في هذا المكان
وسيخرج قريبا فبالتالي الناس كلها تتجمع
هنا وتتجمهر هنا نايف لذلك حتى لا يقع عمل
عمل
يطلب مني ايضا انه ابتعد ايضا لا ادري ان
كان سينقطع الاتصال ام لا لكن ساحاول قريب
من الكاميرا نحن فقط نريد الكاميرا يعني
ان امكن ذلك غسان فلذلك لا الكاميرا
الكاميرا قريبه جدا الكاميرا قريبه من
الموقع وهي في مكان ممتاز يعني وكما
تشاهدون الصوره
الطفله وهي التي تتابع طبعا هذه العمليه
على شاشه العربيه كما يعني ذكر على جد هذه
الطفله وايضا لكل المشاهدين الذين يرصدون
طبعا هذه اللحظات يتابعونها ربما
يعني قلق وكذلك شيء من التفاؤل بان الفتاه
عائشه لا تزال على قيد الحياه بعد ان اكد
خالها بانها لا تزال بصحه يعني ربما ليست
بصحتها الجيده او الكامله ولكنها لا زالت
عائشه وربما قالت له بانها قريبه من مكان
الحفر والانقاذ من الاسفل تابعنا عمليتين
مختلفتين عمليه الحفر والانقاذ من الاعلى
ومن الاسفل ربما ان العمليات توقفت من
الاعلى كما ذكرت غسان والان فقط تم
اختزالها على العمل من الجهه السفليه وقبل
قليل تابعنا اخراج الطوب واخراج ايضا ربما
يعني قطع حديديه من
يعني وسائل التدفئه التي كانت موجوده في
البنايه التي انهدت بشكل كامل مستمر من
الاعلى لكن بوطيره
فقط للاشاره هو العمل مستمر من الاعلى لكن
بوتيره ابطا ويبدو انهم يستخدمون الان
اجهزه استشعار او كاميرات حراريه ولكن
العمل مستمر من الاعلان لكنه بشكل ابطا من
الوتيره التي تشهدها العمليه عمليه عمليه
الانقاذ في الاسفل على اي حال تتواصل حتى
هذه اللحظات عمليه اخراج الانقاض وتتواصل
[موسيقى]
نعم لا ادري انا اسمع جلب هناك على كل حال
على اي حال يعني تدخل الشرطه في هذه
اللحظه يشير ربما الا انه بات يعني بتنا
على بعد دقائق قليله من اخراج الطفله
عائشه لا يريدون ان يكون هناك اي يعني
تجمر مما يعيق عمليات الانقاذ فبالتالي هم
يطلبون من الناس الابتعاد عن هذا الموقع
الذي نقف فيه نعم وتستمر عمليه الاخراج
الانقاذ نايف كما تشاهد في الصوره ربما
انت تشاهد صوره افضل مني لاني انا طلب مني
لكن العمليه الان يعني الان الصوره امامنا
وهي محاوله اخراج اكبر يعني كميه ممكنه من
الطوب المسلح الموجود طبعا
في هذه
البقعه او في هذه المساحه ايضا من الموقع
هذه الصوره حتى الان وبشكل سريع غسان لم
تكن تشاهدها يعني
نعم انا اشاهد جزء من هذه الصوره وخالها
موجود الان على
القرب من الثغره الموجوده الموجوده من
الثغره نايف وما زالوا يواصلون عملياتهم
وما زالوا يواصلون رفع الانقاذ طلبوا ماء
طلبوا ماء لا ادري ان كان هذا الماء
للطفله ام ان كان لي
احد عناصر الانقاذ لكنهم طلب ربما افراد
من لا اعرفها الان او من الجيش
يتوجهون الى هذه المنطقه احد المسؤولين
ايضا
العسكريين ايضا في هذه
بطبيعه الحال نعم يشاركون نعم بالفعل هناك
الالاف من العسكريين الاتراك يشاركونا في
عمليات الانقاذ هو ليس مسؤول هو احد
الاشخاص الذي كان هذا الذي تشاهده الان هو
احد الاشخاص الذي كان في داخل هذه الحفره
قبل تقريبا نصف ساعه وبالتالي هم يشاركون
في عمليات الانقاذ نايف هناك اعداد كبيره
هناك يعني بالالاف من عناصر الجيش التركي
يشاركون في عمليات الانقاذ ودعم واسناد
فرق الانقاذ الموجوده في جميع المواقع
يحتاجون لمزيد من الدعم يحتاجون المزيد من
الدعم تشاهد نايف انت عمليه انقاذ طفله
استمرت يعني سته ايام والان اخرجوا
شقيقاتها قبل ساعتين او اكثر من ساعتين
وما زالوا يعملون على اخراجها علما بانها
يبدو كانت قريبه من شقيقاتها لان شقيقاتها
اكدنا انهن انها بخير وبصحه جيده لكن يبدو
انها محاصره في محاصره في موقع معين موقع
يعني صعب جدا الوصول اليه وبالتالي تتواصل
هذه العمليات لكن حتى اللحظه نايف
المؤشرات الجيده والمطمنه هي تسارع وتيره
العمل هي لحظات الصمت الكثيره ومن ثم
العوده الى العمل بشكل سريع هي استنفار
رجال الامن وابعاد الجمهور طلب زجاجه ماء
كل هذه مؤشرات يعني مطمئنه ايضا تحضير فرق
الاسعاف لمغذيات وتحضير النقاله التي سيتم
نقلها فكل هذه مؤشرات جيده ومطمنه حتى هذه
اللحظه
ما زلنا نستمر في هذه التغطيه ومواصله هذه
التغطيه لمحاوله انقاذ الطفله عائشه من
تحت الانقاض قضت يعني سته ايام اكثر من
125 ساعه وهذا يعني شبه معجزه نايف ان
تبقى طفله ان يبقى ثلاث طفلات بهذا العمر
الطويله بدون غذاء ولا ماء ولا تدفئه ظروف
جويه قاسيه جدا كانت تمر فيها البلاد وحتى
هذه الساعه درجات الليل متدنيه جدا تصل
الى مادون السفر بالتالي
ننتظر هذه الدقائق الصعبه والطويله
ابلغونا قبل قليل انهم على يعني بعد
تقريبا عشر دقائق لكن مضى عشر دقائق الان
ويبدو انهم يقتربون اكثر من ذلك
لايف ما هي الظروف داخل هذه الحفره ما هي
يعني العوائق الموجوده داخل هذه الحفره
وبالتالي لا يسعنا سوى الانتظار والانتظار
الى حين خروج عائشه على قيد الحياه باذن
الله وهذا المشهد نايف الذي تشاهده هو
مشهد يمتد على جميع المدن يعني
اخراج يعني هذه
الفرش او ايضا ربما ايضا سرير النوم يعني
نحن نتمنى انها تكون يعني قريبه في هذه
اللحظات
واضح انهم نعم واضح انهم اقتربوا من غرفه
الطفله عائشه بما انهم تمكنوا من اخراج
هذه
بهذا الحجم نايف فهذا يؤشر على مدى اتساع
الفجوه او الثغره في الداخل وبالتالي ممكن
ان يكون هناك يعني اقتراب اكثر واكثر من
الطفله عائشه وتشاهد انت
اكوام التي تخرج بالحجم الكبير والسرير
الذي خرج طبعا حجمه كبير وبالتالي هذا
يؤشر الى مدى اتساع هذه الفوهه وربما يعني
تخرج عائشه بوقت قريب كنت اقول نايف بان
هذا المبنى الذي يحاولون اخراج عائشه منه
هو مؤلف من خمس طوابق عائله اسره عائشه
كانت تعيش في الطابق الثالث كما فهمنا من
خالد طفله عائشه كانوا يعيشون في الطابق
الثالث في يوم امس كانوا
لحظه صمت الان يطلب
لحظه صمت جديده فراق الانقاذ والشرطه ايضا
تطلبها من الموجودين حول
المكان حول
البنايه وحول ربما الغرفه التي كانت
تقطنها طبعا هذه الطفله عائشه ربما هي
غرفه النوم لاننا شاهدنا قبل قليل اخراج
سرير نوم للاطفال
وايضا كذلك الفرشه التي يعني تغطي هذا
السرير تم اخراجها من هذه
من هذه الكومه كومه
الانقاض وطبعا
المبنى المدمر بشكل البنايه المدمره بشكل
كامل بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب هذه المنطقه
نعيد التذكير مشاهدينا لمن انضم الى الان
نحن نتابع عبر شاشه العربيه بشكل حي
ومباشر رص لعمليه انقاذ الطفله عائشه ذات
السبعه اعوام من تحت الانقاض في قهرمان
مرعش التركيه
وتابعنا قبل ذلك انقاذ اخواتها
الاثنتين وتم اخراجهن من تحت الانقاض وهن
بصحه سلامه كما اكد جدهن والان هذه
محاولات ايضا
يعني متتاليه حتى هذه اللحظه طلب من
الموجودين في هذه المنطقه الصمت لاكثر من
تقريبا اربع مرات خلال اقل من خمسه عشره
دقيقه
المحاولات لا زالت يعني بشكل مستمر وكبير
ومضني ايضا من قبل المسعفين والموقرين
محاوله تحديد مكان الطفله عائشه بشكل دقيق
طلب الصمت لاكثر من مره هناك عدد يعني لا
باس به من المنقذين
[موسيقى]
رجال كذلك الشرطه على ما اعتقد لا ادري
هناك يعني جلبه حدثت فجاه لكن لا افهم
يعني لا افهم ماذا يقولون لكن يبدو ان
هناك لا ادري ان كانوا استدعوا سياره
الاسعاف ام لا دعنا ننتظر لنشاهد
شيئا ما هم طلبوا
انهم نايف لحظه نايف فقط لو سمحت لي يبدو
انهم عثروا على شخص اخر على قيد الحياه
يبدو انهم عثروا على شخص اخر على قيد
الحياه هكذا شخصين
شخصين غير الموجوده
شخصين يبدو انهم عثروا على شخص اخر غير
عائشه على قيد الحياه يبدو انهم عثروا على
شخص اخر على قيد الحياه
يعني محاوله العثور على ناجين اكثر يعني
فهذا طبعا خبر مفرح وسار اكثر بصراحه يعني
غسان دعنا نتابع يعني حسب الانباء الاوليه
نايف الان حسب الانباء الاوليه هناك هناك
شخص اخر مع عائشه على قيد الحياه
يحاولون الان
الوصول اليه
لانقاذه ايضا كما يحاولون الوصول الى
انقاذ عائشه لا ندري حتى
طبيعه الوضع داخل
تحت الركام
اعتقد ان هناك عناصر من ينزلون او على ما
اعتقد عناصر من الاسعاف التركي
ينزلون الان باتجاه الحفره ويبدو ان هذا
مؤشر على اغتراب خروج
عائشه او ربما الشخص الاخر الذي وجدوه
بالصدفه ربما يكون اقرب من عائشه لكن على
اي حال نحن موجودين وننتظر حتى هذه اللحظه
كنت تسال عن هذا المبنى
عائشه تعيش بالطابق الثالث نهار المبنى
اشخاص بقي ثلاث نجت شقيقتان بقيت شقيق
ثالثه الان يتحدثون عن شخص ثاني عالق
موجود تحت الانقاذ
ايضا من من حتى الركام الان يتم اخراجها
من المكان يعني يبدو ان اللحظات
لحظات استدعاء رجال
الاسعاف في انها يعني تؤشر الى اقتراب
عائشه او الشخص الاخر الذي
نعم هذه منذ وقعت جلبه عندما سالنا ما
الذي يجري قالوا انهم وجدوا شخص اخر على
قيد الحياه وهذا يعني نايف اخبار يعني
ساره
الاشخاص ونتمنى يعني ان تتمكن فرق الانقاذ
الناجين تحت يبقى عامل الزمن هو العامل
الذي ضد كل محاولات الانقاذ الذين يعملون
بالنجاه في اقرب وقت نحن نتحدث عن سته
ايام مرت عن 125 ساعه اكثر من ذلك ونتحدث
عن ظروف صعبه جدا عن ظروف جويه صعبه جدا
كل هذه العوامل تجتمع ضد فرق الانقاذ
وتجتمع ضد العالقين تحت الانقاذ نحن نتحدث
عن مئات الالاف من الاطنان نايف متراكمه
جبال من الاطنان متراكمه في البلدات
والمدن التركيه في الجنوب نحن نتحدث عن
الالاف من عمال الانقاذ وعمال الاغاثه
وايضا عشرات الالاف من المتطوعين الذين
يحاولون تقديم يد العون لفرق الانقاذ هنا
ونتحدث ايضا عن فرق انقاذ دوليه تاتي
للمساعده والمسانده بكافه الوسائل وعن
مساعدات انسانيه كارثه حقيقيه نايف كارثه
حقيقيه متواصله منذ سته ايام كارثه لم
تنتهي بانتهاء الزلزال وانما بدات بعد
الزلزال نايف اثار الزلزال ما زالت حتى
هذا اليوم تهز جميع البلاد في تركيا وفي
سوريا وفي العالم كله نايف السلطات تقول
بانها رصدت حتى هذا اليوم اكثر من الف هزه
ارتداديه وهذا ما اكثر
المباني الايه للسقوط في ايه لحظه
وبالتالي اي هزه ارتداديه ارتداديه تتجاوز
مقياس
محدد معين على مقياس ريختر ويمكن ان يؤدي
الى المزيد من الانهيارات لحسن الحظ تم
اخلاء جميع هذه المباني الاله الى سقوط
وتم اجلاء المواطنين الى مراكز ايواء
ومخيمات انشات مخيمات طوارئ انشات كما تم
اجلاء الالاف من عشرات الالاف من الاشخاص
الى مناطق اخرى يعني جوا ان كان جوا او
برا
فهي مصيبه كبرى لكن المصيبه تبقى موجوده
حتى اللحظه تحت الانقاض وفوق الانقاض وفي
المخيمات ومراكز الايواء
باتوا بلا مسكن في ليله وضحاها باتوا بلا
مسكن وبالتالي تتعهد السلطات في تامين
مساكن لهم خلال عام تامين مساكن جديده
وبناء مساكن جديده خلال عام لكن التحدي
كبير وضع اساوي جدا كارثه حقيقيه نايف
والان مازلنا بانتظار خروج عائشه ان شاء
الله وشخص اخر ايضا يقولون انه ما زال على
قيد الحياه صحيح ربما قبل قليل في الصوره
انا لا اعلم ان كنت قريبا من
الكاميرا او تشاهدها بشكل كامل اعلم انك
انه طلب منك طبعا الابتعاد ربما قليلا عن
المكان لكن هناك فرق من ربما المنقذين
وكذلك احد رجال
الاسعاف يعني نشاهد قبل قليل بانه نزل الى
داخل هذه الحفره ذات الحفره او ذات يعني
المساحه المحاصره فيها الطفله عائشه نشاهد
الان اخراج بعض ربما الادراج او ايضا
الخزانات اجزاء خزانات
الملابس ربما التي كانت في غرفه الطفله
وكما نوهت انت ايضا قبل قليل بان احد
الموجودين ذكر بان هناك شخص اخر لا يزال
على قيد الحياه موجود ايضا بالقرب من
الطفله عائشه وهذا ما نتمناه
غسان وكذلك كل من يتابعنا الان هذه
العمليه التي نتابعها الان واياكم على
شاشه العربيه هي عمليه انقاذ للطفله عائشه
بعد ان تم انقاذ اثنتين من اخواتها
واخراجهن من تحت الانقاض ونقلوا لمستشفى
قريب من هذه المنطقه منطقه طبعا كهرمان
مرعش وهي مركز زلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا على مقياس سبعه
فاصله سبعه على مقياس رختر طبعا الان ربما
نقلت تقترب من ولا تقترب صحيح ربما هناك
محاوله فعلا ستخرج في هذه اللحظات هذا ما
نتمناه نشاهد هذه اللحظات نحاول نعم نحاول
ان شاء الله يعني ان يتمكنوا من اخراج
عائشه والشخص الاخر من تحت الانقاد لكننا
نترقب هذه الدقائق ولحظات الصعبه نايف لا
نعلم حتى اللحظه الى اين وصلوا لكن واضح
ان هناك توتر وواضح ان هناك وتيره سريعه
في العمل
ويحاولون يعني
ادراك الوقت قبل ان يدركهم وبالتالي تستمر
هذه العمليه ساحاول لاختراق اكثر
نعم
فهم يحاولون الان الوصول
لا ندري ان كانت عائشه التي هم اقترب
شخص الذي عثر عليه بالصدفه طبعا نايف خلف
الكاميرا خلف الكاميرا يقف طابور من
المسعفين لاستقبال النقاله خلف الكاميرا
يقف طابور من المسعفين وهذا المشهد لم يكن
منذ قليل نعم في في
النقاله ايضا حتى المسعفين لاستقبال نعم
النقال تقترب وهناك
طبعا الاسعاف الان نعم نعم فالان نحن
نتحدث عن شخصين نتحدث عن شخصين يبدو انهم
اقتربوا كثيرا منهم كل المؤشرات الان نايف
تشير بان يعني اللحظات اقتربت اقتربت
كثيرا
اقتربت كثيرا لاخراج
الشخصين او ربما عائشه او لا ندري من
سيخرجوه اول او ان كانوا سيخرجوهم الاثنين
معا لكن ما اشاهده الان نايف وانا سياره
الاسعاف تتاهب المسعفون يقفون في صفين
متقابلين استعدادا لحمل النقالات حين
خروجها من بين حين خروج الاشخاص من تحت
الركام لنقلهم فورا الى المستشفى الكل
الان يقف على اعصابه الان الكل على اعصابه
نايف والكل ينتظر الكل ينتظر يبدو انهم في
اللحظات الاخيره من اخراج
الفتاه عبد الله هل من معلومات جديده عم
بقول صار في اثنين لحد الان بس اقرب
وصلوا لرجلين عائشه
نعم يعني متى متوقع لازم حاليا لازم تطلع
ان شاء الله يعني في اي لحظه نعم نايف
يعني كما استمعنا الى خال الطفله عائشه
يقول في اي لحظه يمكن اخراج
الطفله عمليا نايف توقفت عمليات الحفر
عمليا توقفت عن لا ادري ان كنت تسمعني
نايف توقفت عمليات الحفر ما انا ادع كل
الوقت لك يعني عم يتوصف المشهد بشكل كامل
المشهد لدينا هو الكاميرا يعني مقتربه
كثيرا من يعني مكان الحفره الموجوده فيها
عائشه ولذلك صوره لديك اوسع
نعم نايف هذه الصوره تشاهدونها لكن الصوره
خلف الكاميرا تاهب كامل لعشرات المنقذين
والمسعفين
طابور باتجاه سياره الاسعاف يعني طريق
سالك باتجاه سياره الاسعاف بشكل فوري
سياره الاسعاف تتاهب الان طبعا عشرات
المواطنين الان يتجمعون والكل يستعد
لتصوير هذه اللحظه وهذه اللحظه يعني
المبكيه المحزنه نايف
فالكل يستعد الان ممكن خلال لحظات نعم
يطلبون الصمت الان اخرى طلب اخر للصمت
لمعرفه تحديد المكان بدقه الان نحن لا
نتحدث عن الطفله عائشه فقط تحت الانقاض
نتحدث عن شخص اخر يعني ربما
وجد تحت الانقاض
وهو على قيد الحياه الان النقاله تدخل
نايف طلبوا بالتاهب طلبوا للمسعفين ان
يتاهبوا وواضح انهم اقتربوا كثيرا الان
الان نحن في اللحظات الاخيره يا الله الان
نحن في اللحظات الاخيره
طبعا احد المنقذين طلب من المسعفين ان
يتاهبوا في هذه اللحظه والنقاله كما قلت
نايف تقترب من الثغره التي نحن
ننتظرها الان ننتظر خروجها الان ان شاء
الله لكن لا ندري ان كانت عائشه ام ان كان
الشخص الاخر الذي عثروا عليه بالصدفه نايف
لا ندري ان كانت عائشه او الشخص الذي عثر
عليه هذه الاخبار نايف دائما قلناها
ونكررها هذه الاخبار تبعث الامل في نفوس
عشرات الالاف وربما الملايين الموجودين في
جنوب تركيا تبعث الامل في مواصله العمل
للبحث عن ناجين تبعت الامل
لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه تتواصل هذه
العمليات
لا ادري هناك اشارات
يعني الذي يجري لا اعلم لا اعرف ولكن ربما
نحن تغطيه
نايف نحن
نضطر ان نصمت الان طلب منا ان نصمت نشاهد
الان يعني اعتقد انه هذا غطاء حتى يعني لا
تعلم يعني كيف وضع المصاب وللمصاب حرمه
يعني فلذلك
اعتقد انه غطاء حتى يبدو انهم يقتربون
كثيرا نحن صحيح
الطفله عائشه في هذه اللحظه امامنا الان
انا اشاهدها امامي اذا عائشه الطفله عائشه
تم اخراجها الان العربيه ترصد لحظه انقاذ
الطفله
عائشه انا اشاهدها معك غسان لكن هناك
التفاف كبير
اشاهدها الان تم انقاذها ايضا خرجت بعد
ثلاث ساعات من الانقاذ خرجت وهي بصحه ربما
ان شاء الله في هذه
اللحظات بعد سته ايام عاشتها تحت الانقاض
يعني وتم اخراج حتى اخواتها من المكان
اليك الصوره والصوت ايضا
نعم نايف لكن طلبوا منا ان نصمت يعني لكن
عائشه عائشه الان نايف الحمد لله عائشه
خرجت من فم الموت صحيح عائشه الان تخرج
بعد ولاده عسيره واولاده قيصريه نايف
عائشه تخرج من رحم الركام نايف صحيح لا
ادروها الاتصال
جيدا
ونذكر مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام العربيه
كانت ترصد معكم لحظه بلحظه محاولات انقاذ
الطفله عائشه الان واخراجها من تحت كومه
الركام وهي
تسمعني قطع الاتصال ان كنت الان انا اسمعك
جيدا
الان يثبتون الان الان نايف
الان نايف بسرعه بسرعه
الان نايف نايف ان كنت تسمعني ان كنت
تسمعني جيدا ان كنت تسمعني
طيب
تسمعني بشكل جيد الان يعني
اكتب
نعم عائشه على اكتب في المسعفين باتجاه
الاسعاف عائشه عائشه يا نايف عائشه تخرج
من رحم الركام عائشه تعود للحياه عائشه
تخرج من فم الموت نايف عائشه بعد ولاده
قيصريه بعد ولاده عسيره عائشه الان الى
الاسعاف الان تصل الاسعاف نايف
وتحمل الان بالاسعاف تحمل بالاسعاف الان
لحظه فرح لحظات فرح كما تستمع كما تستمع
الكل هنا في حاله فرح الكل هنا في حاله
فرح عائشه الان في الاسعاف نايف عائشه
تتجه الان الى المستشفى
وتنضم لشقيقاتها تنضم لشقيقاتها فاطمه
وخديجه
نحو ثلاث ساعات مضنيه نايف نحو ثلاث ساعات
مضنيه ومتعبه على الجميع على اخوالها وعلى
جدي
صحيح لحظات يعني صعبه تابعناها معك بعد
انقاذ الطفله عائشه
نتمنى ان شاء الله انها تكون بصحه وسلامه
الان اكمل معك هذه التغطيه ستبقى معي لكن
الان اسلم الهواء الى الزميله فاطمه فهد
التي ستكمل معك هذه الساعه الاخباريه اليك
فاطمه
شكرا نايف وطبعا الشكر ممتد اليك غسان على
هذا المجهول الجبار في تغطيه عمليه
الانقاذ لاكثر من اربع ساعات غسان والحمد
لله انتهت بفرح عظيم بخروج الطفله عائشه
لتلوث
بشكل واضح ومستمر
بكل تاكيد
يعني خرجت عائشه عائشه كما قلت قبل قليل
خرجت من رحم الركام خرجت بولاده قيصريه
بولاده عسيره المهم خرجت عائشه خرجت لتنضم
لما تبقى من اسرتها لشقيقها فاطمه وخديجه
على الشاشه غسان اثناء حديثه صور للطفله
عائشه حصلنا عليها من عائلتها ومن جدها
ارسل لنا صوره للطفله عائشه وها هي تع على
شاشه العربيه حصريا الان اثناء حديثنا
غسان يعني بكل فرح وبكل سرور شاهدنا معكم
لحظه بلحظه عمليه انقاذ الطفله عائشه
البالغه من العمر 7 سنوات والتي تنضم الى
شقيقاتها او شقيقتيها تحديدا بعد خروجهم
من تحت الانقاض قبل اكثر من ثلاثه ساعات
تقريبا وشهدنا هذه العمليه معكم على
الهواء مباشره غسان كنت ذكرت ان هناك صوت
اخر يسمعونه ام كان ذلك صوت عائشه ايضا
نعم بالفعل طبعا سالنا قبل قليل قالوا لنا
لا اخر ربما هم اختلط عليهم الامر مع
اصوات عائشه او حركه عائشه فاختلط عليهم
الامر بس على اي حال لكن على اي حال فاطمه
انتهت هذه الماساه على الاقل لاسره واحده
لعائله واحده وهي عائله عائشه التي كانت
تنتظر منذ سته ايام والتي كانت تعتقد يوم
امس بان الطفلتين التي علينا عليهن في هذا
المنزل
خلفيات ومشوهات كانوا يعتقدوا انهن بناتهن
لكن بعد ذلك عاد الامل من جديد عندما
اكتشفوا بان هناك اصوات تحت الانقاذ وهناك
عالقين اخرجوا شقيقتين ومن ثم اخرجوا
عائشه اربع ساعات تقريبا
فاطمه وهم يحاولون اخراج عائشه ولم تكن
بعيده اكثر من متر او متر ونصف وهذا يشير
كم التعقيد والخطوره في عمليه الانقاذ وفي
عمليه ارتشال الناجين بسبب هذا الركام
وهذه الاطنان من الركام فاطمه لذلك عمليه
معقده ولذلك هي ساعات طويله وساعات من
الاشاده
بمهنيه على الاخرين وجديه فرق الانقاذ
الذين قاموا على هذه العمليه وجميع عمليات
الانقاذ الاخرى يعني صبر كبير
وترقب عظيم ومهنيه وجديه
خصوصا باستخدام اليات تقليديه اليات
بدائيه هذا هو الشخص الذي اخرج الذي اخرج
عائشه عائشه يبدو ان هذا هو الشخص الذي
اخرج عائشه من تحت الانقاض لا ادري ان كان
يعني
هذا هو الشخص الذي يعني يقول لي انه هو
الذي اخرج عائشه من تحت الانفاق
والتعب مدى الانهاك يعني يتحدث التركيه
فلا اعتقد انه يعني يستطيع التحدث لكن
تشاهدين حجم التعب
والارهاق يعني نتحدث عن ساعات طويله طويله
جدا في هذا العمل وما شاهدناه اليوم وما
رصدناه اليوم
منذ اربع ساعات الى لحظه انتشال عائشه
والذهاب بها الى المستشفى وانضمامها لما
تبقى من اسرتها من شقيقتيها يعني هو جزء
بسيط مما يجري في عموم المدن التي تعرضت
لهذه الكارثه وهذا الزلزال وما زالت حتى
هذه اللحظه عمليات الانقاذ متواصله فاطمه
وما زالت عمليات المساعدات متواصله حتى
هذه اللحظه ونامل ان يكون هناك الف عائشه
والف فاطمه وخديجه يتم
او اكثر او نجاه كل العالقين الناجين من
تحت الانقاذ اتمنى ذلك غسان وهل من انباء
عن وجود مزيد من الاحياء تحت هذا المبنى
تحديدا والذي يتكون من خمسه طوابق كما
ذكرت ام انهم سينتقلون الى موقع اخر الان
هذا المبنى على الاقل الان انسحبت فرق
الانقاذ بعد الانتهاء من عمليه
الانقاذ الاخيره التي تم انقاذ فيها عائشه
يبدو انه لا يوجد فيه عالقين وكان هناك
عالقين لاستمر العمل بطبيعه الحال وبشكل
مؤكد يعني لكن يبدو انهم انتهوا من هذا
المبنى هذا مبنى من خمس طوابق انهار على
رؤوس ساكنه طبعا العمل كان مستمر فيه منذ
سته ايام فاطمه وبالتالي يبدو ان عائشه هي
اخر الناجين في هذا المبنى يبدو ان عائشه
هي اخر الامل في هذا المبنى انتهت لحظات
الصمت الطويله في هذا الموقع وفي هذه
البقعه بالذات فاطمه لكنها كان لكنه كان
صمتا من ذهب كان صمتا من ذهب فعلا عائشه
خرجت وعائشه عادت الى الحياه مجددا وكتب
لها عمرا جديدا من جديد لكنها يعني
هذا العمر الجديد وهذه الولاده من جديد
غسان معك لحظه بلحظه منذ اربع ساعات ونحن
نتابع عبر كاميرا العربيه غسان ومعك ومع
زميلنا باسل خلفه الكاميرا لحظات انتشال
الطفله عائشه البالغه من العمر سبع سنوات
لتلتحق
باختيها فاطمه وخديجه الذين تم انقاذهم
صباح اليوم وايضا مباشره على كاميرا
العربيه وتم نقلهم عبر الاسعاف مع خالهم
الى اقرب مستشفى من تلك النقطه وبعد ذلك
باشر المنقذون عمليات الانقاذ لاستخراج
شقيقتهم الثالثه وهي
عائشه التي شهدنا خروجها من تحت الركام
بفضل الله وللاسف طبعا عائشه فاطمه
وخديجه فقدوا والده والديهم ولكن يبدو ان
جدهم معنا الان مجددا غسان اليك
طيب ينضم الينا هاتفيا جد الطفله عائشه
التي تم انقاذها اهلا بك معنا
يعني هل لك ان توصف لنا شعورك الان يعني
بعد خروج حفيده ثالثه لك من تحت الانقاذ
وبعد سته ايام
اهلا وسهلا اتوجه بالشكر والحمد لله رب
العالمين من الدرجه الاولى وكما وتوجه
بالشكر لقناه العربيه التي قامت بالبث
المباشر ونحن على اعصابنا وقريبه اعصابنا
من الانهيار كما يتوجه بالشكر الى كل ما
قام بمساعدتنا بهذه الرحله وقاده وحكومه
ومسؤولين ورجال امن وفرق دفاع مدني وفرق
قال وفرق
انقاذيه والى كل من اعطى وما بمساعدتنا
وكان يتابعنا لحظه بلحظه والى كل ما قام
بالدعاء لنا في كل انحاء العالم واطلب
منهم الدعاء ان يكون ان يكون الله عونا
لنا على حسن تربيتهم بما يرضي الله في
باقي ايام كيف هي صحه فاطمه وعائشه وهل
تمكنت من الاطمئنان على عائشه عفوا فاطمه
وخديجه
تكلمت مع فاطمه وخديجه وهم بصحه كامله
وجيده
وكانهم يعني كانهم لم يكن هناك اي شيء
ولكن جزاهم الله خيرا
بالعنايه المشدده
لاستمرار رؤيه الاطمئنان عليهم ان
يتابعوا حالتهم بشكل الكامل ووضعهم ممتاز
جدا جدا جدا
عائشه لا اعلم اي شيء حاليا انا اتابعكم
على على القناه وبعدها سوف اتكلم مع
اولادي في متابعتهم الحمد لله على سلامتها
سيد اشرف شكرا لانضمامك لنا ونتمنى لكم
ولجميع السلام طبعا
اكرر وانا اكرر جزيل الشكر لكم على هذه
المتابعه ولا هذه حسن
يحسن النيه وحسن المتابعه
ولا ادري ماذا ساقول ولا يعني وانا عاجز
لساني عاجز عن كل من تقدمت بالشكر له
يعني الانسان بكل بكل شيء
يقوله
اشرف
يعني عمل لا
عمل انساني لا يقدر بثمن جزاكم الله كل
خير جزاكم الله كل جميعكم كل خير شكرا لك
سيد اشرف لانضمامك ونتمنى السلامه للجميع
ونحن نشاهد معك اثناء حديثنا سيد اشرف صور
لخروج عائشه حفيدتك من هذه الحفره ومن تحت
الانقاض صور كنا نقلناها مباشره قبل قليل
عبر كاميرا العربيه
للحظه انقاذ الطفله عائشه البالغه من
العمر 7 سنوات ذات الجنسيه السوريه من تحت
الانقاض من مبنى مكون من خمسه طوابق سقط
في
قهره في تركيا جنوب تركيا
على عائله هذه الطفله وجميع العوائل الذين
كانوا يعيشون في هذا المبنى الذي سوي
بالارض اذا لحظات اخراج الطفله واسعاف
الطفله عائشه
بعد خروجها من الانقاض بعد سته ايام بقيت
تحتها على قيد الحياه من دون غذاء من دون
ماء ومن دون تدفئه كذلك ولكن بفضل الله
خرجت وهي كما نرى في الصور تستجيب لمن
يتحدث ويعني تهز براسها بالاستجابه وانها
تفهم ما يقولون وانها بخير على ما يبدو
ولكن ربما اشعه الشمس والضوء شديد على
اعينها بعد ان بقيت في العتمه والظلام
الدامس لمده سته ايام
بطبيعه الحال لنستمع قليلا الى هذا الصوت
الطبيعي
خرجت بعد ثلاث ساعات
اذا هذه هي الطفله عائشه البالغه من العمر
7 سنوات لحظه انتشالها من تحت الانقاذ هذه
العمليه تابعناها نحن منذ اربع ساعات ولكن
كانت بدات قبل ذلك بوقت كثير نحن يعني
شاهدنا هذه اللحظات منذ اخراج اخواتها
فاطمه وخديجه وايضا تابعنا لحظه بلحظه
عمليات ومحاولات اخراج عائشه كانت عمليه
جدا صعبه وطويله استمرت لمده اربع ساعات
بسبب ربما
يعني موقعها تحت الانقاض لا نعرف تفاصيل
عن حاله وجودها تحت الانقاذ ولكن ربما
تريدنا بعد قليل هذه المعلومات وسنطلعكم
عليها حال تمكنا من ذلك بكل تاكيد يعني
فرق الانقاذ حاولوا من عده مناطق ان
يخرجوا عائشه بدايه حاولوا من نفس الحفره
التي خرج منها اخواتها ولكن لم يتمكنوا من
اخراج عائله عائشه من نفس الحفره بالتالي
ذهبوا الى فوق
واستخدموا اليات متوسطه
لتكسير الحطام والحفر حفره جديده استمرت
هذه العمليه ثلاث ساعات ونصف
لحفر حفره جديده والاستخراج عائشه منها
وهذا الذي حصل بفضل الله نجحوا من اخراج
الطفله عائشه من حفره جديده حفروها رجال
الانقاذ باستخدام اليات متوسطه وباستخدام
ادوات تقليديه وبدائيه كما شاهدنا خلال
الثلاث ساعات الماضيه معكم مشاهدينا وفي
هذه الصور تحديدا التي نراها امامنا هي
لحظه خروجها من تحت الانقاض ولحظه محاوله
اسعافها وتغطيتها
ويعني تثبيت الرقبه بهذه الاداه المثبته
في حال لا سمح الله كانت مصابه او كانت
تاذت من وجودها تحت الانقاض
اذا تابعنا واياكم ومع كاميرا العربيه
لحظه انقاذ شقيقتين الفتى عائشه في مدينه
قهرمان مرعش التركيه
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله الله جميعا الحمد لله الحمد
لله رب العالمين الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
ورغم تضاؤل فرص العثور على ناجين تحت
الركام بعد مرور سته ايام على وقوع
الزلزال الا ان فرق الانقاذ استطاعت
انتشار الاحياء تحت الانقاض اليكم ابرز
الناجين في اليومين الخامس والسادس
[موسيقى]
الف الحمد لله
[تصفيق]
افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان ان
حصيله ضحايا الزلزال المدمر ارتفعت لتصل
الى اكثر من 5000 قتيل كما افاد المرصد ان
حصيله الضحايا مؤهله للارتفاع الى اكثر من
7000 ضحيه في سوريا وذلك لوجود مئات الجثث
تحت الانقاض باعداد بعداد المفقودين وذكر
المرصد كذلك ان فرق الانقاذ تواجه صعوبه
في الوصول لبعض المناطق وذلك لتواجدها ضمن
مناطق نفوذ النظام السوري
قدم برنامج الغذاء العالم التابع للامم
المتحده مساعدات غذائيه طارئه لمئه وخمسه
عشر الف شخص في تركيا وفي سوريا عقب وقوع
الزلزال المدمر في البلدين الاثنين الماضي
المنظمه او منظمه الامم المتحده اعلنت
ايضا عن توسيع نطاق مساعداتها الانسانيه
والاغاثيه لتشمل نحو 900 الف شخص من
متضرري الزلزال
اداره الطوارئ بدورها اوضحت في تركيا ان
الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب شرقي البلاد
الاثنين الماضي يماثل انفجار 500 قنبله
ذريه في تاثيرها المدمر واعلنت السلطات
التركيه في وقت سابق اليوم ارتفاع اعداد
قتلى زلزال الى 25 الف وتزايد اعداد
المصابين الى 80 الف بالاضافه الى الالاف
من المفقودين حتى الان
معنا من القامشلي مراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش
جمعه اهلا بك معنا اذا كنت ذكرت لنا سابقا
ان كان هناك اعلان لوقف عمليات البحث عن
احياء وعمليات الانقاذ كيف هي الصوره الان
جمعه
يعني ما بيقها لولا فسحه الامل هي تلك
الحياه التي يبدو ان طفلين من
جنديرس قد حظي بها مره اخرى رغم ان كل
يعني التوقعات
والاراء قالت بان لا احياء تحت الانقاب في
جلديرس لدينا معلومات جاري التاكد من
صحتها بان فرق الدفاع المدني تمكنت من
انتشال طفلين على قيد الحياه في بلده
جنديرس التي يعني شهدت اكبر نسبه من
الدمار على مستوى سوريا ايضا ليله امس كان
هناك انقاذ لطفلين في مبنى في جبله في
مبدا رحاوي في جبله الذي قتل في هذا
المبنى لوحده اكثر من 40 شخص بفعل الزلزال
يعني رغم انه الاعمال يعني تكاد تنتهي لكن
بين الفيله والاخرى يعود هذا الامل ويتجدد
من تحت الركام وكاننا يعني امام معجزات
حقيقيه تحدث فيلم بلدين في سوريا وفي
تركيا وكانه هناك قدره الهيه تقول لا
تياسوا ولا تفقدوا الامل وهو ما يشجع طبعا
فرقه الدفاع وفرق الانقاذ لتكثيف عملياتها
كما يجري الان في جنديرس وايضا في مركز
مدينه جبله تابعه الى اللاذقيه وايضا في
مركز مدينه اللاذقيه حيث فرق
الانقاذ والبحث تسارع زمن بحثا عن الناجين
يتجدد الامل بالعثور عليهم في هذه
المساحات والبلدات الواسعه المنكوبه على
امتداد الجغرافي العثور على اين جين في
الساعات الماضيه جمعه
يعني خلال اليوم ونصف لم يتم العثور على
ناجين لكن في جنديرس تم العثور على قفلين
يعني هناك معلومات عن انتشار طفلين على
قيد الحياه في جنديرس وليله امس تم انتشال
ايضا شخصين في بلده في مدينه جبله التابعه
لمحافظه اللاذقيه العثور على هؤلاء يعيد
الامل بان هناك احياء اخرين تحت الانقاض
رغم انه يعني فرق الدفاع فرق الدفاع
المدني والانقاذ في على طرفي يعني
المعارضه والنظام اكدوا بان الفرص قد
انتهت حتى ان الدفاع المدني اعلنا بانه
انتقل من مرحله يعني الانقاذ الى مرحله
انتشار الجثث لكن تحدث المعجزات اذا اذا
من يقوم بعمليات الانقاذ جمعه والبحث عن
ناجين هل هم المدنيون
هناك فرق متخصصه في البحث في المباني
المدمره من الدفاع المدني شمال غرب البلاد
عن ناجين
البحث عن ناجين تحديدا جمعه من يقوم بها
يعني لانك ذكرت بان الجهات الرسميه اعلنوا
الانتقال من عمليه البحث عن احياء الى
عمليات انتشار الجثث فمن الان يقوم بعمليه
بحث عن احياء هو نفس الفريق لكن يعني
صادفهم وجود طفلين على قيد الحياه في مبنى
مدمر وقاموا بان هذه معلومات نحن نتاكد من
دقتها لان المعلومات وصلتنا للتوبه ان
هناك طفلين تم انقاذهم من تحت احد احد
المنازل المدمره في
جنديرس نواصل مع الدفاع المدني للتاكد من
هذه المعلومات لكن ليله امس تم انتشال
شخصين من مبنى الريحاوي في مدينه جبله نفس
المبنى الذي تم العثور فيه على 43 جثه
يعني 43 جثه مقابل شخصين على قيد الحياه
في مبنى سكني واحد جمعه من اين تنضم الينا
انت تحديدا انت بالقامشني ولكن اين تحديدا
يعني ارى خيام كاني وراك خلفك يعني
هل هل نستطيع ان نرى هذه الخيم لجمع
التبرعات وتحويلها الى السوريين في
المناطق المتضرره سواء في مناطق النظام
وايضا في مناطق المعارضه طبعا هناك
العشرات من الحملات
المحليه رجال اعمال اصحاب شركات
منظمات عشائر تقوم بجمع التبرعات ومن ثم
شراء يعني
مواد طبيه
وتحويلها الى مناطق النظام والمعارضه لكن
كل هذه المساعدات بما فيها مساعدات التي
قدمتها الاداره الذاتيه لا تزال حتى اليوم
يعني منذ ثلاثه ايام وحتى الان عانقه على
المعابر الواصله بين هذه المناطق ومناطق
المعارضه من جهه ومناطق النظام من جهه تح
في معبر ام جنود الفاصل بين بين مناطق
الاكراد ومناطق المعارضه وفي معبر التايهه
الواصل بين مناطق الاكراد ومناطق النظام
يعني منذ قليل وصلتي معلومات ان هناك
خمسين شاحنه اخرى محمله بالوقود اتجهت الى
معبر التائهه وفي هذا المعبر هناك ايضا
خمسين شاحنه عالقه لا يسمح النظام بدخولها
وايضا هناك 32 شاحنه في معبر ام الجود لا
تسمح المعارضه بالدخولها مما يعني ان
الخلافات الاسباب هذا المنع جمعه لماذا
النظام السوري يمنع دخول القافلات
المساعده الانسانيه
تراكم الخلافات السياسيه وايضا العسكريه
غياب التنسيق بين هذه الاطراف المتصارعه
منذ حوالي 12 عام وحتى الان يمنع الدخول
هذه المساعدات لكن في المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها المعارضه السوريه هناك خلافات
عسكريه وسياسيه
وقطيعه تامه بين مناطق الاداره الذاتيه
وهناك تدخل من الجانب التركي وتحكم بقرار
المسلحه والمعارضه المسلحه
يغلق هذه يعني المعابر امام تدفق
المساعدات الداخليه بين السوريين انفسهم
ويفوت على المنكوبين فرصه الحصول على
الدعم من السوريين الاخرين في مناطق
السيطره الاخرى هناك اي محاولات امامية
للتدخل في هذا الشان شان المعابر
والقافلات القافلات المساعده العالقه في
هذه المعابر
هناك يعني مناشدات من السوريين المنكوبين
مناشدات من بعض يعني القيادات للامم
المتحده وللدول الفاعله في المشهد السوري
وتحديدا روسيا وامريكا للتدخل والسماح
بدخول هذه المساعدات او على الاقل اعلان
هذه المعابر مفتوحه امام المساعدات
لفتره محدده ليس ما يتم التعامل مع
تداعيات هذا الزلزال طبعا يعني تواصل مع
روسيا مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع
تركيا اي على المؤثرين في المشهد السوري
لكن لا لم يحدث يعني اي تطور على الارض لم
تفتح هذه المعابر حتى الان اذا كان الوقت
يسمح دعيني اذهب الى خبر عاجل هناك الان
يعني 22 شاحنه محمله بالمساعدات الاغاثيه
والطبيه تدخل من معبر باب السلامه باتجاه
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا 15 شاحنه منها للامم
المتحده وس الشاحنات لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه تحمل ادويه ومعدات طبيه صغيره
ستدخل باتجاه مناطق شمال غرب سوريا الى
هذه هي القافله الثانيه للامم المتحده
تدخل من معبر باب الهواء في اتجاه المناطق
الموكوبه في شمال غرب البلاد هذه وصلت
لباب السلامه خمسه عشر منها للامم المتحده
وسبعه منها
لجهات اخرى ابقى معنا جمعه سنعود اليك
لتفاصيل اكثر حول هذه المساعدات التي اتت
الى باب السلامه ونذهب الى ريف حلب حيث
ينضم الينا الصحفي احمد ابو لؤي سيد احمد
انقل لنا الصوره لديك
نعم تحياتي عزيزتي فبعد مرور خمسه ايام من
كارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب المناطق شمال
الغربي سوريا طبعا اعلن الدفاع المدني عن
انتهاء عمليات البحث في انقاذ العالقين
تحت الانقار في مناطق المنكوبه بالتلزال
مبتدا بعمليات البحث والانتشار بعد شبه
انعدام وجود الاحياء طبعا الاحصائيه
النهائيه
بلغت اكثر من 2166 حاله وفاه اكثر من 2950
مصاب طبعا بجميع المناطق الحيز الاكبر
الذي كان في نصيب منطقه جنديرس
هنالك الوفيات اعدادهم خمس مدينه
بالنسبه
لاوضاع
المصابين طبعا
يعني
المساعدات الطبيه بالنسبه للمساعدات دخل
يوم امس
بعد شاحنه من معبر
من معبر باب السلامه في مدينه اعزاز
الشمال حلب مصدرها كردستان العراق من
مؤسسه البرزاني وبعض المتبرعين من الجهود
في تلك المنطقه طبعا ودخل 14
من معبر باب الهواء طبعا محتويات هذه
القوافل الغالبيتها طبعا مستوياتها في
الابتدائيه الى
النظافه واضافه
المشاهدات
انت الان عند دخول قافله من الامم المتحده
ومنظمه الصحه العالميه من معبر باب الهوى
اضافه انباء بعد ساعات ستدخل قافله مقدما
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اوضاع النازحين بالالاف ما زالوا في
العراء تحت اطفال الزيتون في حاله الطقس
البارده
لجا الى اقربائهم المقيمين في احواش عربيه
او منازل يعني ارضيه لرسم هي اقل
للعرضه لاهلديه
[موسيقى]
قبل قليل
بعد انقطاع الامن من دخول
من
الجراءات
يتقطع قليلا السيده احمد ابقى معنا كرمان
سنعود اليك ينضم الينا من مدينه سرمدا
شمال ادلب منير المصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع
المدني السوري اهلا بك معنا سيد منير يعني
كيف تصف الوضع لديكم الان وهل مازال هناك
امل بوجود احياء تحته الانقاض
في الحقيقه بعد سته ايام من العمل
المتواصل المتواصل دخلنا اليوم السادس
طبعا استطاع الدفاع المدني الوصول الى
اغلب الى كافه المناطق المتطرفه وكافه
الابنيه المتضرره وقام بعمليات البحث وسحب
العالقين من تحت الانقاض طبعا من هم على
قيد الحياه حقيقه ال 24 ساعه الماضيه كانت
خاليه من الاشخاص الذين هم على قيد الحياه
كافه الاعمال كانت هي للاسف بانتشال ضحايا
كانوا قد فارقوا الحياه جراء وجود وجودهم
تحت الانقاذ ومنذ قليل يعني تم ابلاغ فراغ
الدفاع المدني باحتمال وجود عالقين وهم
على قيد الحياه في احد المناطق ذهب الفريق
طبعا متواج المنطقه مباشره توجه الى هذا
المكان تم يعني
عمليات البحث التقنيه والتاكد وللاسف يعني
كان هناك مجرد اشتباه ولا يوجد يعني اي
دليل وهو الان يعمل على
الجسر هؤلاء الجثث هم للاسف ليسوا على قيد
الحياه طبعا الخبر انتشر انه انتشال يعني
طفلين على قيد الحياه ولكن للاسف هذا
الخبر غير مؤكد نتمنى لو كان هناك لازال
اشخاص هم بحاجه الى سحب وهمم يعني لا
زالوا على قيد الحياه الحقيقه بعد سته
ايام يعني هذا شيء طبيعي ومعروف لدى كل
المنقذين ان بعد 72 ساعه من موضوع
الانهزامات في مثل هذه الكوارث يكون من
الصعب بالامكان من الصعب بمكان ان ان
نستطيع ان ننتشر عالقين طبعا العالقين تحت
الانقاذ يكونوا قد تعرضوا
اعرضوا الى لماذا السيد منير من الصعب
لطول الفتره ام من الصعب لقله الامكانات
وضعف وجود المعدات التي تساعد في عمليات
الانقاذ
هلا انا اتكلم ان بعد 72 ساعه بغض النظر
عن وجود المعدات يعني عندما يكون هناك جرح
نازف او يكون هناك يعني اصابات هرس في بعض
اجزاء الجسد او كسور في بعض الاجزاء الجسد
الاخرى هذه الاصابات ستكون بعد ثلاثه ايام
هي اصابات تصل الى مرحله ان تكون قاتله
بشكل كامل عمليات الحرس
يختلط العظم مع الانسجه مع مع الشرايين
والدماء وبالتالي يرفع نسبه التسمم داخل
الدماء ويكون يعني احتمال ان يبقى الشخص
على قيد الحياه احتمال ضعيف جدا هذه من
الناحيه العلميه اما موضوع الصعوبه من
الناحيه التقنيه والمعدات فهذه صعوبه اخرى
يعني تضاف في شمال غرب سوريا لفريق
الانقاذ يعني ممكن ان يكون كان هناك دعم
يعني
كان هناك جسر جوي باتجاه مناطق سيطره
النظام وجسر جوي اخر باتجاه مناطق تركيا
نسال الله ان يخفف عن جميع المصابين جراء
هذا الزلزال ولكن للاسف يعني لم تصل هذه
المساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا بنفس
الطريقه التي تساهم هذا يعني معاناه اخرى
ولكن انا اتكلم من ناحيه تقنيه عندما نصل
الى هذا الوقت الطويل سته ايام يبقى فقط
ممكن احد يعني على قيد الحياه في منطقه هو
محصور وليس تحت الانقاض يعني كلمه محصور
هو غير قادر على الخروج من مكان هو موجود
فيه اما محصور بمثلث يعني ضعيف ولكن لا
يوجد اي اصابه بجرح او خدش او او اي شيء
بالنسبه للاماكن الموجوده في الشمال غرب
سوريا استطعنا ان نصل الى كافه الاماكن
المحصوره فل يعني القوس البيضاء يعني
اعلنت منذ تقريبا ساعات قليله انه انتقل
من عمليات الانقاذ وسحب العالقين الى
عمليات الانقاذ هو انتشال الضحايا لانه لم
يبقى فراغات في هذه المرحله كيف يتم
التعرف على الجثث وكيف يتم اخبار ان كان
لديهم عائلات على قيد الحياه كيف يتم
اعلامهم
هلا في الحقيقه يعني في هذه المرحله عندما
يتم انتشار اي جثه من تحت الانقاذ يكون
المدنيين متواجدون وهم ابناء المنطقه
ابناء هذا الحي الذي تعرض لهذا الانهيار
وهم قادرون على ان يتعرفوا على هذه الجثث
بسهوله اما الجثث التي لا يتم التعرف
عليها يتم
حفظها بارقام محدده وارسالها الى بعض
الاماكن لحفظ هذه الجزر طبعا هي برادات
مخصصه لحفظ هذه الجثث ويتم الاعلان ان
هناك جثث مجهوله في هذا المكان في حال اي
مفقود واي احد يعني يتم البحث على يتم
مراجعه هذه البسس
ومعاينتها من ذوي هذه الجثث حتى نستطيع ان
نصل الى معرفه هذه الاسماء اسماء هؤلاء
الاشخاص وتسليمهم لذويهم من اجل يعني
معاوده دفن بشكل يعني عاوز دفن لاحقا هذه
العمليه طبعا تتم بتنسيق كامل بين مديريات
الصحه بين مكتب دسم الموتى تتم
القوز البيضاء بالكامل بحيث يتم التعامل
مع كل جثه تم سحبها من تحت الانقاذ حسب
يعني المعلومات المتوفره لدى فريق الانقاذ
بشكل مباشر
طيب شكرا لك من الشمال ادلب منير المصطفى
نائب مدير الدفاع المدني السوري
مع مرور اليوم السادس منذ وقوع الزلزال في
سوريا وتركيا ورغم تراجع الامل بالعثور
على المزيد من الناجين الا ان فرق البحث
لا تزال تنقذ العديد من الضحايا اخرهم
سيدتان قضوا اكثر من 122 ساعه تحت الانقاض
نتابع
[موسيقى]